jacob chunas on the hill tonight for the
royals 27 years of age 6'3 220 pounds
sinking fastball curve slider changeup
and he goes down and hits that one out
to monday and with the shift that is 6-3
from the right side of the infield and
two down and now francisco lindor
dorr is cleveland's all-time leader in
home runs by a shortstop 130.
fastball down is lifted to left field
here comes alex and he gets there to
make the play and that's the inning so a
good start for jake one two three and
out tristan mckenzie makes his third
major league start tonight the 23 year
old lanky right-hander
6-5-165 payoff pitch
so little insider is it no strike three
call dozier thought it was inside he's
shaking his head going back to the first
base dugout and boy did that fastball
have some run on it now the payoff pitch
and strike three called a knee-high
inside corner fastball
mckenzie strengths out a pair and the
indians and the royals are scoreless
after one not tyler naquin left-handed
hitting right fielder now the duo swung
on blasted to deep center field back is
mary field and it is gone
a home run to the right of center field
for tyler naquin and the indians have a
two nothing lead here in the second
trista mckenzie against michael franco
mackenzie's pitch is swung on and
whacked to dead center back is to
shields jumps made the catch crashes
into the wall falls to the turf and
hangs on and he took extra bases away
from franco delino de shields made a
heck of a play the pitch strike three
called on the inside corner three
strikeouts now for mckenzie at the end
of two innings tristan mckenzie much
sharper tonight
swing animus struck him out on a
breaking ball and that is strikeout
number four for mckenzie now the wind
and the o2 pitch
swing and a miss my goodness does
mackenzie look good tonight he's perfect
through three innings he has struck out
five wow this stuff is electric two on
and two out here's josh naylor he was
out on the ground ball to second base in
the second inning
and a shot off of junas
the underhands to mcbroom but that got
him solid it looks like on his right arm
at least he grabbed his right arm he
immediately told ryan mcbroom that he
was okay but we'll see top of the order
for the royals whit merrifield to lead
things off there's a swing and a high
fly ball to center
settling under it and making the catch
just shy of the warning track is delino
de shields
that's hit hard to the left side and
lindora got a glove on it but no chance
to get dozier and that's the royals
first base runner kenzie from the
stretch for the first time tonight
delivers swung on ground ball to short
up with it
lindor to second for one on to first
double play
there it is
junice's night is done kyle zimmer comes
on to pitch for the royals here's the
one two and a wave and a miss at a pitch
down
and there's the strikeout for zimmer so
he retires the first hitter he faces and
the pitch
and that one is down did he go around
yes third base umpire jordan baker says
that's a swing and that's two strikeouts
in a one two three fifth for kyle zimmer
we go to the home fifth inning two
nothing cleveland and up to the plate
steps alex gordon who struck out his
first time up
alex on a no two pitch hits it to the
gap the shields is able to cut it off
alex is digging for two
he will be in there and mcbroom goes to
third
absolutely love that hustle by alex
gordon here's his pitch
ground ball first base side grab by
santana steps on the back for one throws
back to third and it's in time mcbroom
stopped and then tried to go back to
third and he is thrown out tristan
mckenzie a three-hit shutout a struck
out six
swinging a topper back to the mound and
bobbled and by mackenzie glove thrown on
the run by lindor got him now routine
play that mackenzie didn't make and then
lindor had to make a tough charge
barehand grab and throw the wind and the
pitch
and it's swung on grounded sharply but
right at the second baseman hernandez
throws him out how about mackenzie he
had a 10 pitch inning and the royals go
in order and the indians have runners at
first and third with one down in the
ninth stomach's pitch and it swung on in
a shot deep right field this ball gone
tyler naquin with a three-run bomb to
right his second home run tonight and
it's tyler naquin five kansas city
nothing brad hand is 10 out of 10 and
save opportunities this is a non-save
opportunity now the 2-1
swung on grounded sharply towards second
field and in shallow right hernandez
spins throws ball game the indians have
pitched their major league best sixth
shutout and take the kansas city royals
five to nothing